oh là là je n'ai pas trouvé de jeux
vidéo pour faire une vidéo aujourd'hui
oro
c'est moi le père noël je viens tout
juste du pôle nord en roumanie pour
t'amener un jeu vidéo halo tu ton
tellement bien je n'avais pas d'idée
pour faire une vidéo aujourd'hui c'est
ça ma vie aujourd'hui les amis on est
avec l'unique suply enfin ouais non mais
je voulais venir le retrait de la base
je suis très content de vous montrer
enfin par l'ipad mais le jeu sur lequel
je bosse depuis plusieurs mois on est
plusieurs dessus et je suis très content
d'enfin le sortir ça sort aujourd'hui
vous cliquer avec votre doigt pour le
télécharger gratuitement alors alors il
faut savoir que ce que tu n'as jamais vu
une seule image j'ai jamais vu une seule
image du jeu et je suis hyper content
que je sois le premier à tester c'est un
quiz
ok c'est un peu comme une possible crise
crédit quiz tout ça avec des questions
totalement débile ouais et un
présentateur très énervant ouais tu vas
perdre très régulièrement ouais ok voilà
c'est un an comme sur tous les jeux
vidéo comme sur tous les pc le jeu de la
rage ok s'appelle le 9 quiz est ok c'est
parti on sait comment t'appelles-tu
comment aller lucasfilm
c'est bon tu t'appelles bien verrue
plantaire a indiqué un élu dont il ya
plein de noms différents voilà donc
n'hésitez pas à dire dans les
commentaires
quel nom que j'avais je suis allé un
easter egg allez c'est parti easter egg
au bout de deux centièmes non ça te met
on vraiment
[Musique]
très bien verrues plantaires c'est parti
pour le quizz question 11 à 20 questions
1 à 10 adacore sépare pas les 10 et
voilà c'est ça les trois virages vi
question numéro une de plus de égal
j'habite de jeu mais je vais dire 4 ce
que je suis naïf et qu'on n'allait pas
de but c'est bien tu as compris moi
cette fois je vais leur mettre à
plusieurs
tu as compris le principe du jeu tu es
très perspicace il est très mignon
j'adore ça lui va très bien
question suivante quel est cet animal la
doc la ja tu m'as dit ripley tu vas
quand tu maintiens ce que tu veux dire
gérable et l'effort chauve souris
montrent religieuse en plus la vue du
gala des golden bombay que je sais
franchement on dirait du raf mai cheka
c'est quoi la douille ta cave une fois
que tu as canet à une chauve-souris là
dedans ou une autre religieuse ou un
iphone moi j'irai les autres jouent les
éléphants c'est ce qui paraît le plus
drôle parfait mais c'est vrai c'est une
ville très ça c'est parfait je fait long
feu mois bond à l'écran on reconnaît
aisément l'éléphant grâce à sa célèbre
tombe et ses fameuses échasses classe
les du plus léger au plus lourd au final
de bronze une pomme en plomb l'humour du
présent à la fois quatre minutes à faire
donc je sais pas trop le situer une
pomme en pomme ça pourrait être une
pomme en raison par exemple plus léger
qu'une plume un peu ou pas c'est que
j'arrive pas situer le bois jeux classés
dans l'ordre bloquaient put avec
l'attendu vous avez un délire vous ne
pouvez pas lâché l'info je ne m'interdis
tels jean pierre foucault des gens bien
comme co je peux pas aider écoute une
pomme en pomme
ouais une pomme en plomb
un tank de l'urss ouais et l'humour le
présentateur je pense qu'il est très
très lourd et laquelle de ces leur vie
n'existe pas barbie caissière au
mcdonald's barbie secrétaire barbie
présidente des états unis barbie
nutritionniste il y en a trois qui
existe vraiment j'hésitais entre barbie
question du mcdonald's et barbie du
sionisme parce que barbie castilla au
mcdonald's c'est vraiment trop précis
pour qu'il existe après je sais pas en
étions surpris brasier et ben voilà
cette vidéo j'ai vraiment pas envie de
re ag est-ce que c'est pas barbie
nutritionniste du coup c'est un peu
abusé du coup j'ai un bon mec à jeunesse
que trois buts en moins de choses en
même temps mais c'est là qu'elle est
celle que j'aime bien c'est qu'il ya un
peu qu'on le tue relayant depuis le
changer je voyage mais le recaler
souvent dans des conversations quelque
chose paris
mais qui les distraient auquel 189 437
via un jeu comme ça sur ds que j'adorais
et j'étais très fort
dense était massée qui avait la réponse
juste avant bah oui mais c'est parce que
ta question il se peut qu'ils aient des
running gag à 189 4
je vais me leberquier savoir quel
drapeau n'existe pas à un petit peu de
culture bajec le numéro gauche celui-là
tout le monde perd que j'ai pris les
drapeaux les peluches loups de la
planète
j'en ai inventé un et voilà c'est quoi
je fais un bisou sur sa doit y avoir
beaucoup de chance on a fait tester la
famille que le premier qui réussit à
donc j'ai pas le premier à tester le jeu
choqué et déçu choqué des succès divers
secteurs et des stuart est passé finit
lesquels de ces films ne met pas de new
york en danger star wars cette baisse à
new york en danger savoir cette tribune
a déjà une une bonne teinte on attend
quoi
genre si je perds je pas mon bac estime
que je m'excuse je met hors de ses new
york leur fils seigneur 2012 c'est toute
la planète man of steel j'ai un doute et
volcano j'ai un doute en fait déjà eu
trop de chatte avant de la juger puis me
permettre
bon ce serait mieux tu perds deux doigts
de la chance incroyable mais ça marche
quelquefois par question raconte luis
enrique à la tête de la statue de la
liberté qui roulent dans la ville c'est
sur ces seniors il ya un montage parce
que c'est vraiment 25 minutes qu'il est
sur une culture incroyable j'aime
franchement hostile cet homme est très
très content c'est l'art de la question
13 comme encore touring tour avec des
allumettes avec des briques avec du
ciment avec un architecte
bon allez avec des allumettes tu fais
plaisir il fait un avc dès que j'ai
décrit mauvaise réponse
architecte à d'accord auquel il est bon
avec du ciment
avec des briques h d'affaires une tour
avec ok c'est bon quelle belle tour à
tusson j'attends le convertir dans le
btp bien sûr quand j'arriverai sur
youtube bien sûr j'ai dans le btp tout
de suite admirable j'ai un cadeau
ouais donc j'ai un double cadeau j'ai le
jeu plus le cadeau dans le jeu ouais tu
as gagné un vieux bonbons trouve au fond
de ma poche fait plaisir il fait plaisir
c'est celui que tu as pris de ses
comptes à payer l'addition hyper cher de
tous les temps et que t'as jamais mangé
la vie parce que tu avais la chair taper
de la chaire donc tu dois je vous prends
un bonbon lesquels de ces dinosaures
n'ont jamais existé à
non je suis nul en débat avec je te jure
velociraptor ça existe ah non mais
[ __ ] c'est pas ça la question mérite à
tort elle avait un mérite à temps
hipster à tort dégage le darwinopterus
quoi ah ouais on a pris des noms les
plus verts oui nos petits russes m'ont
guère il ya autant de lettres dans le
mot vrai que dans le mot faut rester
limitée par ailleurs mon gars mais je
crois je m'étais déjà fait la réflexion
jeune et belle couche je le savais déjà
tu as pris ta boussole ou et le nord tu
peux tourner le bouton et ipad d'accord
t'es fort en attend là bas car et
devenir mes calculs est pressée que j'ai
pas vers d'autres immeubles telle regard
à ton point de vue c'est que bon bon
quand tu en as marre de réfléchir tu
évoques le doigt de la chance c'est là
je crois que tu es tu roule dessus donc
mais non quoi le nord est là bas
l'évolution shaper était le nom et par
ben ça va changer ma life tum quel âge
25 ans 30 50 70 ans mercy la chirurgie
milan comme les momies milan comme les
momies tu me donnes 25 ans si c'est vrai
que je veux plus jeune que mon âge mais
avec des compliments je ne suis pas un
garçon facile le match pas du tout une
dictature faire et pas du tout besoin de
25 pour ça que c'est un personnage assez
sèchement à ces connards à ces connards
c'est comme ces imposteurs connard
écoute l'extrait de plus vous vient ce
bruit chewbacca grassement et est ce que
le oui tu m'as 15 c'est pas grassement
de pintendre esseiva sale type
sa grâce au simple et l'excellent de
lévitation
c'est une porte à moins que juste pour
là c'est une porte d'entrée sur la table
a vécu pendant cinq minutes et emploi
a deuxième cadeau une statue de bronze
vraiment génial qui ressemble
étrangement au présentateur
on se demande pourquoi ils à le voir
génial bien les gains sont de plus en
plus barré il ya des trucs même un peu
obscène et ben voilà on a fait vingt
questions questions 21 à 36 à l'or et
aux eaux se calment on arrête aucun
survol l'on peut pas tous les jours vous
découvrirez par les gens vont découvrir
par eux-mêmes
c'est la fin j'ai fait mes vraies
questions jory faire la suite tu veux
pas bleu tranquille tu peux faire la
suite je le ferais chez moi je serai
chez moi c'était très sympa tri fils de
[ __ ] riz mais aussi les petites
connaissances donc c'est vraiment attend
l'instant promo tu as que 10 secondes 10
ha ça fait lourd la promo c'est gratuit
assez sûr eyeos il android ya pas
d'achats in-app
n'hésitez pas à mettre 5 étoiles stade
de la plus nous ferait très plaisir et
il y avait des gens très tôt j'ai vu ni
l'instant propice fini merci de donner
des mises à jour gratuites il ya un
season pass à 45 euros renault en fait
il ya une partie des questions et puis
on va reçu des questions 20 questions 20
questions
cyprien aujourd'hui je suis fier de te
remettre le trophée du meilleur créateur
de jeux on dirait vraiment un q lors que
tu as reçu c'est moi qui les ai
fabriqués pour toi pour je vais que je
le laissais cela plus c'était super on
n'y a pas longtemps moi j'avais joué à
un jeu que les fans avaient fait où il a
modélisé la maison mais genre c'est
incroyable well as tu joues un jeu qu'un
pote à toi qui fais depuis des années
fait quoi tu vois donc c'est toujours
marrant comme moi je suis content ça te
plait ça ça fait des mois que toi tu
parles tu vas rien montrer parce que je
ne voulais pas mal avant les vidéos
cultes
du coup maintenant j'ai envie de faire
un jeu mais j'ai pas d'idée il faut qu
il faut commencer si vous faire un show
c'est bien d'avoir une idée des billets
à bas téléchargez ce [ __ ] de jeu et
puis voilà je suis content parce que
j'ai appris où était le nord est
vraiment ça va changer on a très très
peu de plus bas mais ça va changer la
qualité de mes prochaines vidéos sur la
ba oui la c4 mais le nom tu vas faire
c'est quand j'en perds le nom ouais
ne jetez pas déjà voué à vous abonner je
vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo
merci d'avoir joué je vous dis à très
vite sur tout le monde
pis aïe